i've got a bunch of channels that we
didn't really like talk about that i
could
just speed run through okay okay let's
all right all gas no brakes go
to your channel oh yeah oh god love
[ __ ] love all gas no brakes yeah
i just i showed you guys uh him right
he's like the modern day katherine g
but more political like because kasim g
was more like let's just throw a topic
out there
yeah funny but like yeah although
castleman do you actively made fun of
them
yeah in a good way like casamagi's porn
star videos yeah like some of the best
content
on youtube actually if anything maybe
cast from g might have inspired me at
the time like i really enjoyed his way
of
how he would insult them but not insult
them yeah yeah that's great but
obviously he doesn't really do anything
anymore yeah and now he's just an extra
in movies like the transformer movie
what i love about him is that he doesn't
even need to do much
he just lets the stupid people do the
stupid thing
i think because he's willing to go there
and he's friendly with them he gets them
to talk to him and yeah it's really hard
to do i think and a lot of journalists
just can't get them
yeah that he gets yeah like everyone
knows he's just going to be nice like
he's going to show everything
yeah it's really nice like some of my
favorite one will when he went to like
the covid party
oh my god just the biggest cesspool i've
ever seen
how every single time he goes somewhere
somehow people bring up jews like i
don't know how he does
like he'll go somewhere jews get brought
up for being the problem and it's like
what the [ __ ]
is like just leave him alone man [ __ ]
hell it's crazy and i loved it on a part
i think he was on the h3 podcast where
he mentioned like he the reason like his
influence was that like yeah i could go
all these places all around the world
but
the backyard in america is so crazy why
would you not want a documentary yeah
yeah yeah
that's so true i don't blame him man
it's crazy um there's a guy called
honest guide who does like videos about
prague i have no interest in going to
prague i've already been but
he's just he's just so passionate about
prague i just love it i'm talking about
videos
watching videos that you have no
interest in i want to shout out rustic
studies who makes essays about magic the
gathering
i don't know i don't know a single thing
about magic the gathering i do not even
know the [ __ ] rules of magic i've
never played magic in my life
i've played magic a lot but the way that
he breaks down
these concepts in magic are just so
[ __ ]
interesting like i think one of my
favorite videos of his is
he goes through like the history of like
the rarest card in magic
i like how much it's sold for and
everything and black yeah the black
lotus
he made a video on that and like how to
like like how people like
actually verify like that these cards
are just [ __ ] cool
and then like because he starts off
talking about not he starts off
not even talking about magic he starts
off this with this video talking about
rare baseball cards
and the history of like how these like
how these cards
how these cards have sold for so much
and then he pivots that into magic and
it sounds like a good job
[ __ ] amazing like he's a great con
and he's editing his gods here as well
speaking of magic but on the actual
like regular version uh there's a
channel i watch quite regularly called
chris ramsay
i think oh is the guy who does the he
opens the puzzles
he does yeah he's he's like a
professional magician but he also has
his own youtube channel where he
he got famous off of like get buying
these like super hard like 3d puzzles
and like solving them yeah
but he also just does these like videos
where he like he basically like he did
the trend before it was a train he
actually does like the professional
magician reacts
like magic but like he actually has
qualifications because he's actually a
professional magician yeah
and he like kind of like tries to like
he obviously you know magician doesn't
you know tell their secrets right but he
like kind of reacts to it and says like
this is a good magic trick because of
this
and like he kind of pinpointed in ways
where it's like you wouldn't really be
able to see it unless
you were in the same field yeah and like
he's [ __ ] great and
i don't know what [ __ ] camera he uses
but holy [ __ ] his camera quality is like
that red camera dude it's insane like i
want to know what camera he uses because
it's
the most insane quality camera that i've
ever seen there's also obviously
loveliness tech tips of course that
video where he talked about possibly
retiring
like broke yeah yeah that broke me as
well you know like it's such a like it
was such an honest video and you just
can't
help but respect you don't you know what
that felt like it felt like that
was leaving you yeah it felt like that
talk where it was
like your dad's just like so me and your
mom are gonna break up
and uh you know it's i know it's
confusing time for you
that's that's exactly what it felt like
man like honestly it's not your fault
yeah yeah trust me it's not your voice
we've just we've tried everything
you know if anyone deserves to retire
it's lineup yeah man the man has been
like a
staple of youtube and he's yeah he's
been on the grind man he's been on the
grind
and he's just like you know it's obvious
that his you know the company's built up
everyone just [ __ ] loves working yeah
it's just so great it's just so so great
seeing people like you
who seem lovely he could be the biggest
dictator at all i don't know but
like he just seems like such a genuine
nice guy
speaking of uh linus we gotta talk about
his latest collaborator
toomad the [ __ ] oh my god the [ __ ]
crackhead of youtube
like i [ __ ] love to love his content
so much
but my god i go out there with adhd i
watch one of his videos
and i'm like my attention span is
[ __ ] destroyed right now he's that
one friend who you have who you just
can't introduce to people
no like you're like like you're so funny
and i love you but i can't
he he's the one friend that you're proud
to know that he's a friend of you but
you're also ashamed to say that he's a
friend of mine
you know i think i love you man uh
there's a bunch of other channels uh
value select who i've just shown you
guys yes a million times yeah this guy
does like
skits and he's probably the best skit
channel on youtube does some really good
[ __ ] music like genuinely good music
as well
just so [ __ ] funny and he hasn't
blown up yet no he hasn't
[ __ ] insane and i've literally been
like touting this guy to everyone i know
for like
months like every time i go to someone's
house i'm like give me the orcs court
yeah and put on a song you better not
play any [ __ ]
yeah speaking of other uh skit channels
i want to shout out britainic
this is like this is like a channel
that's been like around for [ __ ]
years right but he he's also a skit
channel but he's one of those videos
he's one of those channels that uploads
once every year you know what i mean you
get one video
a year and it's like a two minute skit
most of the time two five minutes gear
but his skits are so densely packed that
it's it's on like another level of
quality like every
every scene in the skits leads into the
other scene perfectly the writing is
just like so top-notch you know you know
when you see like a scene
in like a sitcom or something and you
know it's going through like a hundred
different rewrites
that's the kind of the quality i'm
talking about but because he uh
like he's been around for like nine
years or something but because he up
only uploads once every year
he just he just doesn't like that you
can't do that on youtube anymore right
right
i i mean i also i also watch quackity
but quakti's like that one friend who
like
it's just a piece of [ __ ] but then
they're actually funny what i mean
[Applause]
he is discord as a person you know what
i mean yeah
the guy who when i used to do prank
calls he he doesn't really give any
views anymore he's called hoax hotel and
like he's so good at prank calling and
he knows all the like scams
inside out really good videos by him
with your scam call
back in the day yeah i used to really
like his videos and i thought i found it
like i really liked how he dealt with it
and he would keep them going
uh there's a few other channels as well
god there's the kit boger as well he
does pranks really good
and there's a guy who god don't know his
name but hackness like the indian call
center
that video was insane and that was
really yeah there's there's a lot of
content creators that i don't know their
channel name but i can name that content
video like if i say hey those two indian
guys that build stuff
obviously like critical obviously we
talked about like i feel like pro cd and
critical the same thing but like
different content they're talking about
like they do the same thing essentially
here right but pro cd is like talking
about food and
anime and [ __ ] i mean like meme yeah and
critical is just
dildos and i feel like critical could do
a video about [ __ ] and he's like one
of the few content creators that can
literally do a video about anything yeah
yeah yeah like like he can he can make
like the [ __ ]
top 10 massacres of all time and i'll be
like man if the holocaust ain't at
number one i'm not leaving this video
man
you know what i mean did he recently do
my favorite video where i'm just like
this is a video that only critical can
make which was uh
yeah the favorite condominium so it was
so
disgusting but so good at the same time
like i hate you so much but damn this is
good
yeah um another youtuber i think we've
all watched is the is he
he won't know his name but kewami japan
is what he's called but he's the dude
who makes knives yes yes
on every one of his videos is i hate to
be in a jail cell with him
true true there's a guy called virtually
vayne he also did prank calls he doesn't
really upload much he did one recently
but he was like the god of prank calls
he did like a great african uh like he
did like african dictator or something
foreign
he's the guy who does the he's like the
only channel i like that does like
reddit videos
like when he like reads a subreddit like
all the other ones are [ __ ] right
are you talking about the [ __ ] ask
reddit videos where it's just like this
computerized voice
that's just like [ __ ] awful i hate
those buttons
all the time oh my god this is like
whenever
whenever sydney does any makeup or
anything i just hear ask reddit this
time
i might be [ __ ] those videos man
but like sorrow tv is like actually like
you know where a video that shouldn't
require talent yeah actually brings a
[ __ ] ton of talent
yeah yeah that's sorry tv he's so good
at doing voices and like voicing the
like
reddit thing it's like wow everyone
watches dog [ __ ] wait wait is it is it
actually just these same ass credit
threads but like it's like
it's like a professional voiceover yeah
essentially like it's it's like
they started watching them and i'm just
like man they they [ __ ] leveled up
their voicemails
they've actually got a [ __ ] voice
yeah and it's actually like a guy who's
amazing is like doing voices like he's
so good at like i'm a voice actor but i
can't do that anymore it's like hearing
[ __ ] like uh like morgan freeman or
like
narrate an ask reddit thread you know
what i mean like he'll swap up the
voices
really well he's so good with comedic
timing and yeah he doesn't really upload
anymore
black griffin is like a guy that does
that it's kind of yes i think sounds
familiar yeah
he's the guy who does like the one dude
50 voices or whatever
she was like the [ __ ] daughter of
4chan yeah you know what i mean yeah
just just seeing her debut like debut as
a v
tuber yeah like it's it was just like it
was just like such an obvious choice
and like you didn't think about it until
it happened right like this is a v
i'm just like that's the perfect
marriage of course she was
acting online since like 2013 2014. and
she was still like
the staple yeah yeah i pitched [ __ ]
posting yeah yeah right and that was
back then
and it's crazy to see that she's like
peaking now yeah yeah it's really cool
to see someone doing well who's been
around for so long
uh nerd city obviously yeah as well as
caleb uh i like circle tunes hd as well
that guy just uh [ __ ]
moves i i really i really like how he
was basically because he he can animate
right yeah yeah
he can animate he does he doesn't need
to animate and i feel like it's better
because of that
you must see his videos it's the guy who
has like he he's basically like an
animation youtuber but instead of
actually animating he just like goes
into photoshop and just like
wiggles like his models around oh yes
yes yes yes yes
yeah yeah i like jamie nicholson as well
yeah i like uh
up it's not jump as a as a gaming
youtuber who
like he was the first person who
actually did vr gaming videos
but just made it like he he like i said
he has this perfect line of like
comedic analysis right on on literally
just like
vr games right right because no i've not
seen any other content creator that
focuses on vr games
except for him yeah um and he he
definitely set the bar high
oh that channel's cool but he's been in
my recommended a bunch he like makes
video games and like he made like a
mangas in 30d
and he like remade full guys in like two
weeks it's insane i don't know
comments will let me know yeah that
guy's channel was awesome as well is
there anyone you think is like a loki
weeb
what i don't think people say i think a
lot of them a lot of them are weebs yeah
it's like it's like these last couple of
years like
people who we thought had no affiliation
to anime i just like
yeah i'm a weeb needless to say i forgot
[ __ ] carson call me carson oh yeah
he is he's he's not a loki weep he's a
[ __ ] he's a full degenerate yeah come
to japan already
come on just hang out with us to say
anyone we've spoke
you know good about on or we like
probably can yeah i'd like to come on
the podcast
yeah come to japan everyone like this
this has basically just been a video to
be like hey
these are all the people we watch
everybody who emails you
man come on our podcast this is our
pitch to you not only do you get to come
on the podcast we'll take you around
japan we'll have some good times you'll
be good fun
we'll get drunk plenty